North Korea can hit most of the United
States say US officials the US has
detected highly unusual levels of
submarine activity by North Korea Mike
Pence says all options on the table for
North Korea North Korean ICBM test
longest in the history of the regime US
military set to test a new missile as
early as tomorrow in response North
Korea sebastien Gorka North Korea this
is a result driven presidency that's
ominous
we are now on the threshold of a real
national security crisis with North
Korea surprisingly not fake news from
Andrea Mitchell according to a pentagon
assessment after decades of
international negligence the regime led
by 10 pot dictator and Dennis Rodman
admire Kim jong-un may now launch an
attack not only on Hawaii and Alaska but
also on the continental United States
thank goodness the mainstream media are
diligently focused on president Trump's
third cousin twice removed who once a
force in the 1990s plus will be joined
by a truly deplorable panel of roaming
millennial Amanda presto Giacomo andso
Rachel to discuss the left
Tommy Lauren hypocrisy a professor of
Beyonce's studies the real the real
thing and and a professor who is fired
for the mere act of threatening to shoot
the president and a new study that shows
Americans don't want their doctors to
kill them for some reason
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
so this before this comes from an
unnamed Pentagon official but as
analysts are taking it very seriously
they say that what they're seeing is
highly unusual it does seem to be the
consensus there's some debate over
whether or not North Korea can strike
the US mainland but there seems to be
some consensus that it looks like they
can although it's unclear what those
weapons would do once they reenter and
attempt to strike the mainland forget
about those experts let's look live at
our our live feed camera from Pyongyang
do we have that pod brick oh no oh great
to see you at home
mr. Hill I was supposed to be allowed to
inspect your palace today and your
girl's home let me into certain areas I
can find we've been fruity two dozen
time I don't have anyway please max
Jackie okay I then let me look around so
I can use the u.s. collective mind I
break my bar here are you breaking apart
I'm sorry but the UN must be firm with
you let me see your whole palace or else
or else what
oh he will be very very angry with you
and we will write you a letter telling
you how angry we are that is Hans Blix
still around or there might be old
footage I don't know if that's actually
coming to us live from Pyongyang but
that has been the policy of the United
Nations and all the nations in the
region in the world for the past 25
years they say North Korea if you don't
comply with our nuclear requirements we
are we're going to be very angry we are
we're going to have the sanctions that
are already in place we are going to put
pressure on you now this is not just the
opinion of of Kim jong-il in that clip
or Kim jong-un or Hans Blix or the
international community this is also the
opinion of left-wing favourite Jill
Stein returning here the position of the
South Korean people who have been very
clear that what they want they are tired
of war even have a peace treaty the
Korean War is still on there's an
armistice but the people of the Korean
Peninsula and especially in South Korea
have lived under the threat of war for
decades now they're really tired of it
they would like to move ahead you are
negotiating a peace treaty and you know
the the demonization of North Korea is
part of the run-up to regime change we
saw it in Iraq we saw it in Libya as
part of demonizing a government that we
then want to exercise regime change on
and then what do we get you know look at
our track record here it's not so good
the demonization of North Korea Marshall
can you can you demonize a demon is it
possible is that are they like a double
demon can you demonize Moloch I don't
know if but possibly you can I'm not
sure which is more cartoonish the
marionette Kim Jong Il or the 2016 Green
Party candidate for president I'm not
sure please go on
again it's the North Koreans who've
added the provocation in launching
missiles and testing well cooked but
remember where that came from long
before they began their missile tests
the US was conducting nuclear bombing
runs against North Korea we actually had
nuclear weapons
until the end of the Cold War we
actually have nuclear weapons stationed
in South Korea so this is very
frightening to them they've been
basically cornered in the feeling like
they have to develop a nuclear weapon
you know a lot of people donated to her
and gave her money that's true I think
she went to Harvard too which probably
probably explains it all
so that's true we we have been
maintaining the World Order now even
during this crisis that's gone on for
decades and we have not fired on the Kim
regime we didn't take out the the
grandfather the founder Kim il-sung we
didn't take out Kim jong-il in the 90s
and we haven't taken out Kim jong-un who
is Natalie Durr of North Korea and we've
punted on this through three different
presidential administrations for some
good reasons for some bad reasons first
up when this became an issue was Bill
Clinton the luckiest man in the world
devil protects his own gokhan was very
lucky came at a time after the fall of
the Soviet Union which had been propping
up the the Kim regime in North Korea he
came at a time when Kim il-sung the son
king of North Korea died so that
instituted a period of three years of
mourning Kim Jong Il had to protect
against possible coos even at and there
was this natural disaster major flood in
North Korea which caused famine it just
didn't seem like a big issue at the time
and Bill Clinton was not focused on
foreign policy then George W Bush was
not as lucky as Bill Clinton he walked
in right into 9/11 he was fighting two
wars in the Middle East that were caught
there were reaction to 9/11 and and in
2006 Kim Jong Il detonated the first
nuclear weapon that the regime had ever
detonated so they saw that not only were
they seeking these weapons but they they
finally had attained them unfortunately
President Bush was busy fighting other
wars he didn't turn his attention to
North Korea in any really meaningful way
other than the sanctions and then came
Barack Obama who also did nothing about
North Korea because he's a terrible
president there's no excuses really that
Barack Obama could rely on he you know
totalitarian leaders have this amazing
gift for duping the American Left they
don't know they work some magic or some
charm on them and that's what that's
what Kim jong-il did we have do we have
a cut of Kim jong-il working his charm
on the Left I guess our I guess our live
feed is cutting out our live feed from
Pyongyang maybe the regime found it
maybe the
knew that the war is starting hopefully
not stay tuned you know they've always
been able to do this from from still and
onward and because the left says we need
to focus on problems here we need to
focus on global warming we need to focus
on education we focus on the social
social welfare system and they aren't
too concerned with the international
order so Barack Obama was elected to
wind down those wars in the Middle East
he easily could have turned his
attention to the Pacific which I think
he intimated he would during the 2008
campaign instead Barack Obama instituted
a policy called it's called strategic
patience which is an incredible
euphemism of all of Barack Obama's
euphemisms strategic patience is great
it's similar to leading from behind or
tactically can kicking tactical can
kicking was a with a favorite of Barack
Obama's but what did it get us it got us
more major missile tests it got an
American high school student kidnapped
and killed by the Kim regime so now
Donald Trump has two terrible options
military option now that they have
significant nuclear capabilities or more
sanctions and economic incentives for
the military choice as ever
here is Lindsey Graham there is military
option to destroy North Korea's program
in North Korea itself he's not going to
allow President Trump the ability of
this madman to have a missile to hit
America if there's going to be a war to
stop him it will be over there if
thousands die they're going to die over
there they're not going to die here and
he's told me that to my face and that
may be provocative but not really when
you're a pros in the United States where
is your allegiance lie to the people of
the United States this man kim jungeun
is threatening America with a
nuclear-tipped missile president Trump
doesn't want a war the Chinese can stop
this but to China South Korea and Japan
Donald Trump is not going to allow this
missile ship to be clear right now
that's tough talk from Lindsey Graham
who in fairness I don't know that
Lindsey Graham has ever seen a war he
didn't like it is has definitely been
much more hawkish from the
neoconservative wing of the party but
here Lindsey were senator Graham's view
lines up with that of General Douglas
MacArthur during the Korean War
General MacArthur 1951 he wanted to push
into North Korea he wanted to keep this
going and have an absolute victory to
fight international communism
particularly on the peninsula president
truman disagreed with this he wanted to
keep that war very limited they got into
a tete-a-tete about this it seems as
though perhaps general macarthur was
undermining Truman's initiatives and I'm
not totally sure about this we do have a
video clip of the message that General
MacArthur issued in 1951 can we pull it
up shoot off my lawn
let's no manual for me did you hear me I
said get off my lawn now you ready to go
back and out yeah I blow a hole in your
face and then I go in the house and I
sleep like a baby you can count on that
Lisa stacks IQ 5 feet high in Korea use
you for sandbag maybe that's a
reenactment I'm not sure also a great
job bleeping the one one of 10 swear
words and a clip to a marshal great
producer we but in any case Truman
refused Truman refused MacArthur's
demands which you heard and clip
beautifully played by Clint Eastwood and
so the DMZ the Demilitarized Zone was
set up along the 38th parallel North and
South Korea were firmly established and
the war came to an armistice
now perhaps 65 years later we will
pursue what General MacArthur advocated
possibly too little too late the other
alternative are economic incentives and
economic sanctions it's not very clear
though that these will work North Korean
economy of late has been growing fairly
well between one and five percent
economic growth most estimates have it
around four percent the reason for this
is somewhat complicated China buys 99
percent of North Korea's coal exports
North Korea literally ships its people
out of the country to work as slaves in
in other countries gets about a billion
dollars a year for that and the North
Korean regime still has access to a lot
of the international banking system so
what is President Trump going to do our
leader we have some interesting
situations that will handle North Korea
Middle East
lots of problems that we inherited from
previous administrations but we'll take
care of them we'll take care of them
very well
we'll handle North Korea we're going to
be able to handle them you'll be it will
be handled we handle everything we
handle everything what's all the fuss
about we are going to handle it great
talk from president Trump with that
let's bring in our panel we have from
the youtubes the brainy the beautiful
roaming millennial is with us from The
Daily wire we have the also brainian
Amanda presto Giacomo and then from
everywhere else on the Internet
we have the probably a little less
brainy definitely much less beautiful
so Rachel oh it's good to have him here
as well Amanda why can't we just kill
this guy he isn't a one guy he's in a
third-world country
he's very overweight he has heart
problems why why is he still alive we
should put it in the hands of Lindsey
Graham completely useful sublunary
everyone no measure from Lindsey Graham
of course but we should expect any I
mean it's a really touchy situation but
I do actually I had more I feel better
with President Trump than President
Obama as crazy as it sounds because
nothing again just kick the can down the
road only friends and Trump is talking
about getting China in there and you
know cutting out and putting sanctions
on them and try and do something but um
yeah well crazy right now and we have
Jill sign is insane and then we have
Lindsey Graham is also the biggest war
Hawk single mild-mannered Lindsey Graham
he's so soft-spoken he's so genteel and
he just wanted a gun everybody down
around the world
so the Castros the Kim's the Clintons
why do these terrible families stay in
power for so long what is it about them
that we can't wrench them from power I'm
not saying anything until you say that a
brand edible in the interest of moving
on with the show and also when I speak
from the depths of my heart you are you
are both brainy and you are very
beautiful
so Rachel Oh longings of my heart and my
loins Oh Rachel if you can let that
Floyd man you have you had me at hello
speaking of the longings of loins book
the brick does talk about the Clintons
that gets a point
oh I don't know what it is Matt it's uh
for some reason you know when you're
able to make promises and you're able to
accuse other people of being evil that
just goes a long way
empty promises and accusations go a long
way and that's how these people are able
to stay in power that's interesting you
know roaming the the Trump
administration managed to secure the
release of that American high school
student otto warmbier unfortunately
that mean days later weeks later but
they've still managed to secure the
release which President Obama could not
have worked on it for over a year does
this show a good sign for the Trump
administration and how he's going to
deal with North Korea or are we just as
bad off as it seems well I think there's
definitely a scale here right I mean you
can be better than Obama and still not
be doing so well so far I think in terms
the Trump administration and their
approach of North Korea I did honestly
it's the it's the most hopeful I've been
in a long time something that I do wish
so and this is someone who's lived in
China you know right now I'm in Hong
Kong I think that they have a trump
administration even though they may be
great people good people some of the
best I think they're they're not doing a
really good job in trying to incentivize
China in order to cooperate with their
agenda right because I mean quite quite
frankly I think China does it have a
huge role to play in this but um it's
not exactly in China's best interest or
China's purview right now to a protect
American for an interest in North Korea
and I think until until the u.s. can see
that and can kind of think of a way to
maybe carrot and stick situation with
China they're not really going to budge
you know roaming it's an awfully
convenient time for you to be going over
to Hong Kong while those missiles start
flying over the Pacific here what do you
know have you been colluding with the
North Koreans or the Russians or the or
the Kushner's or what what do you know
yeah I'm just I'm just getting a spar
away from the East Coast as I can I
might be coming back you know sometime
next year and we'll see how the
Electoral College works out in the in
2020 that that is the plan once once we
go up and smoke it then I think roaming
is going to be hosting my show too
you'll have all y'all been the show
you'll have Andrew Clavin show that's a
great strategy should have thought of it
myself
okay now I know that you want to watch
more roaming millennial and so Rachel
and Amanda Prestidge jacquimo but you
can't because you're too cheap unless
you subscribe to daily wire so go over
right now to the daily wire com it is
$10 a month very very little or $100 a
year you'll get the famed leftist here's
tumblr it's what I drink my delicious
salty leftist ears out of every day and
you'll get to watch the rest of the
panel of deplorable we're going to be
talking about doctor-assisted
suicide we're going to be talking about
Tommy Lauren all of those fun things
that you'll only be able to see if you
go and subscribe and give me your money
so go over there right now daily wire
calm and we'll be back with the panel of
deplorable z-- the Tommy Lauren is under
fire she's under fire from the left her
alleged Apocrypha I was over a politican
over this weekend and she did a she did
a debate with Chelsea Handler and there
was this question that came up handler
said what do you do for health insurance
and Tommy Lauren said well I'm only 24
and so therefore I'm on my father's
health insurance plan because under
Obamacare you get to stay on your
parents plan until you're seventy one I
think 71 or 74 they keep changing the
regulation so now the left is calling
her a hypocrite Amanda is she a
hypocrite she's using a perk that is
available under the law but she also
thinks that perhaps in general it's not
a great regulation is she a dirty rotten
hypocrite well first of all we bring
power in that room remark I mean so bad
but I'm sorry I'm sorry but what I'm not
going to attack Tommy here tell me where
it actually Michael no we do a lot of
show prep here at the Daily wire yeah
that's okay I forgive you but it missed
reminds me of the attack I'm president
Trump when he was basically bashing tax
loopholes I'm using them yeah no stuff
and of course he's going to use them
it's such a stupid attack there are so
many things you can go after Tommy Larry
Anam and this is not one of them
like I said it's just like using the
system that's the ants and I didn't
filming against it doesn't make any
sense that's a great point they have
there's so much material at their
disposal and of course the left has to
shoot themselves in the foot and use
everything the word did I have to ask
roaming did who won this debate was it
like the iran-iraq war we just hope both
lose or didn't come out on top America
lost yeah I will you know bad shot the
thing I'm Tony learn you know I don't
see Idaho I with it with her on
everything and but you know she's
I think she has a lot of good arguments
we made and you know Chelsea Handler is
a person so you know human dignity
Annette but you know in general when
yeah I said Tommy learned Chelsea
Handler debate this wasn't any in-depth
policy discussion there was a lot of but
my feelings but ma were so grateful for
me aside so I don't think there were any
real it was about as good as you would
have expected it to be and I mean in
terms of winners yeah I guess it's just
what what what kind of identity politics
you like I don't know like pro America
pro leftism yeah I don't know if anyone
hasn't watched it yet I would give it a
Miss watch ben shapiro a year that is
where all the action it was a great
debate but you guys are a couple of
negative nancies on this though do you
agree with them to agree with with our
two female panelists all you know and
you better you know if you want to get
out here safely it's certain calling uh
i love the saying that you know if
liberals didn't have double standards
they wouldn't have any standards at all
you know so of course they're going to
call Tommy Lehren a hypocrite place but
here's the bigger hypocrisy you got
things like a Chelsea Handler who goes
off on a screaming cursing tirade and
they have accused Donald Trump of
whining and not only that after her
screaming tirade and bragging about who
she has sex where she actually said that
he should act more like a president I'm
like cooler grab her you to judge
somebody and tell them to add more
presidential and how are you going to
have this debate about health care when
you're promoting this promiscuous
lifestyle and then when people get a
sexually transmitted disease they want
to dull a demand at the health care
slave that they're entitled to invite
them a prescription for their aids that
is that is a great racket now always
defend very promiscuous lifestyles but
that is a great racket and I have to ask
on that point though do you think there
were two women in that debate
it was woman on woman do you think that
it this exhibits politicans internalized
misandry is this is this sexism we have
two women on this panel who by the way
get paid 77 cents more on the dollar
than we do is this is that related cons
internalized sexism if this is
this is true feminism this is a very
strange way to show it there should have
been total solidarity on that stage that
there should be no contention whatsoever
you know speaking of feminism speaking
of strong women and strong women voices
we have to talk about a Beyonce studies
professor now there is a New Jersey
professor of women's studies who
specifically teaches about Queen Bey my
cousin Beyonce and he recently tweeted
three tweets quote if I see any Trump
bumper stickers on the road today my
brakes will go out and I'll run you up
the road that's lovely
will the second amendment be as cool
when I buy a gun and start shooting at
random white people or no he he is a
white person himself by the way and
quote Trump is an effing joke this is
all a sham I wish someone would just
shoot him out right now I know that you
majored in Beyonce studies whatever
happened to academic freedom why are
they kicking this important voice out of
the Academy
well first off I gotta say you know
Beyonce studies if there's a bigger
example of the academic left hating the
concept of employment I can't think of
it right but yeah you know I've actually
had some conversations about this with
people who say that oh no you know if we
start to let go of professors who say
things like killing white people is okay
advocating white genocide that's bad um
we're as bad as the left do we start
doing that in my day no I'm sorry but no
you know not wanting actual racists and
you know actual extremists who call for
murdering white people or presidents
around your children in positions of
power I don't think is a you know being
being as bad as a left or you know soft
control and I think it's crazy that most
academics get away with as much as they
do what an uneducated rube roaming
Millennials read a blog for goodness
sake will you get on Twitter so not only
does this professor teach Beyonce
studies and threatened to kill people he
also has a terrible grasp of punctuation
and grammar do you think it's time to
shut down the colleges have the college
has just gotten out of control from
blowing these people oh man one thing
I'm not going to go on the the grammar
not the angle but I'd say you I'm in
this is one thing you
and Democrats with their true KKK colors
on displays for some when any
disagreements first thing I want to do
is I want to start shooting people they
want to blow up churches they want to
set things on fire that's just who they
are this is what they do and I'm hoping
I'm hoping that at some point people
start to catch planted this is what they
are this is what they've always done
this is just what they do are you
accusing the party that founded the KKK
of racism how dare you Darius I am I do
it all yeah no you do it all day Michael
you're wrong because like there was this
magical switch remember when then like
all the races left so yeah I managed
yeah wait so you don't you don't
remember you don't you guys you have to
read blogs you have to start reading
blog it was a time in the 1960s
everybody got together is a big
convention and we all said okay so now I
am Republican I'm going to be a Democrat
and you or you are now going to be
Republicans you do not remember this oh
come Jairus a lot of Maryland there's a
lot of abracadabra in that you know
there's like this sudden big switch but
I love the hole okay here's this big
Exodus this big switch okay go strong
Thurmond who's who's what who else is
with me and then as far as a big switch
well if all the Democrats came over here
where does all the Republicans go but
though in order to refute the line about
the party switching you would have to
read political history from the 1940s
through 1990s yeah that's a lot of
reading to do I can't judge I haven't
been prepared for that in college I got
to go get a job Amanda had the
universities always been crazy or are
they getting particularly bad right now
therapy crazy some more money we put
into them they hit me crazy I mean
Beyonce by the way I mean she is so al
gore is kind of like Joel Osteen for
climate science Beyonce's like literally
Jesus on the last one is the second
coming she is it like it's not just does
that make me John the Baptist since I'm
her cousin because that brats not too
bad the voice of one crying out on
Facebook you eat locusts Ben honey
what's that tastes like me you know that
this University thing is actually pretty
by I usually dig this pretty seriously I
was just back at Yale that place has
been destroyed in like five years
and a part of it is I think the funding
part of it is that the administration
has been so
week about all of these student protests
but is there any light at the end of the
tunnel how are we supposed to fix this
so and he thought oh you know the funny
thing is that is that you know these
institutions they they were Christian
founded and hey you know the snake got
into the Garden of Eden so I you know
the devil cream did that was going to
get into church and he got in there too
you know and the thing is is for some
reason there's this push to qualify
yourself as a sophisticated and
intellectual by disqualifying God and
all their whole pursuits is to get as
far away from that as possible to show
that they are of some secular
intellectual powerhouse and that's
that's a shame and it's because it's
almost like you want to push all this in
t'lay they're just really highly HD that
is a really funny point because I did I
did notice this at Yale there was always
this idea that if you weren't espousing
the secular point of view or the
materialist point of view you were just
some some rube from the hillbilly
countries but the other thing I noticed
is that all of the smartest people I met
they're all I mean a handful of really
bright people I met were Christian or a
Jewish or or you know Eastern Orthodox
or Catholic they all have that in common
they were all God believers now roaming
you are not only a millennial you're the
roaming millennial if you notice this
problem on campuses and do you have any
ideas on how to fix it well I think a
university campuses are kind of like
many hubs for all progressive leftist
policies right so anything that we might
see in large society from the
progressive left is amplified on
University campuses so you know that's
true for any sort of social justice
theories and that's definitely true like
so is saying for things like secularism
and this you know anti religious stance
that the left has been taking
increasingly and I think you know what
is so interesting about it about that is
that you have a lot of university
professors who are espousing you know
the value of secularism I which you know
I don't think secularism might be
inherently bad but then if you hey let's
turn and look at the philosophy
department or the history departments
and oh look Aquinas st. Augustine like
all these great thinkers that you guys
are teaching all those white men
you mean except for Alison I guess was
fairly swarthy probably my skin color
but not Zoe's skin color so he's bad
sorry go on
right it's funny to me how you know they
can have this sort of arrogance when it
comes to people who are religious who
still hold to judeo-christian values but
you know when you actually look at the
subject that they would be teaching so
much of you know classical Western
history and so much of what we hold to
be Western values are built by people
who believe the same things that a lot
of their religious right do now you know
speaking of st. Augustine and two mystic
theology we have to talk about assisted
suicide this is there's actually pretty
good news on this front
even as the universities burn and the
missiles fly over from Korea there is a
new study out of Tarleton State
University which finds that all 43 bills
to legalize assisted suicide in 26
states this year have failed that's a
hundred percent failure rate and that
gives legalized suicide bills over the
last 23 years a ninety-nine percent
failure rate roaming why don't America
--nz want their doctors to kill them
it seems so on seem so obvious it's
weird it's almost as if they don't want
their doctors to kill them and they
don't want their doctors to kill their
loved ones
yeah it doesn't it doesn't make any
sense it's so attractive and appealing
some of my loved ones have a different
opinion on Amanda does this represent a
culture shift from a culture of death to
a culture of life I know unfortunately I
don't think so so every man's yeah yeah
these bills are going to keep on coming
and you know once upon a session starts
I was looking up some data on this and
in Belgium for instance I introduced it
legislation in 2001 and then just it
just kind of produced this slippery
slope and culture of death whereas of
now currently well at one of every 50
death is a they're euthanized
I mean does insanity and now they just
legalized it for children with chronic
illnesses or what have you so I mean it
but it's a really slippery slope so
let's just you know we got to push
conservatives and obviously to combat
this but it's really scary I don't think
it's any great news celebrated things we
still a long way to go that's a great
point you know it raises an interesting
question why this is
different in America than it is in
Europe I'm Surma lenio you were about to
say something well I was just you know
going to say that it it is worrying that
Europe and going this way especially you
know what when it comes to children but
I think part of what might be positive
about that and we kind of see this in
the recent very tragic charlie guard
case is that when people in the US see
these kinds of things happening in
Europe where we see not only a
government kind of takeover of health
care and choices that affect your right
to life or you know living in general I
think it you know it might be a wake-up
call for people here to see like hey if
we keep continuing down this road this
actually will be where it leads to right
am a slippery slope argument is it isn't
always crazy and I think this is an a
very good example where people who are
advocating for these bills in the United
States need to take a good look at
Europe
what they're doing they're like do we
want to be a society where we help
children kill themselves where we decide
that you know what this experimental
procedure for this dying baby not really
worth it I don't really see it right
because I mean in my opinion these two
things are very they're very in twine
but it all has to do with government and
it may be killing you that is a great
point I mean it seems to me that
certainly the Anglosphere should break
off of Europe that brexit they should
try to move the island and maybe we
could increase the space in between the
United States and Europe as well fill up
maybe we need a little more global
warming to fill up that Atlantic Ocean
so do you think that you should be able
to kill your family members oh oh man
that's why I asked be that what do you
know about my family anyway what do you
know that I don't know what do we I
think I think the base of just where
it's really flawed is that I reckon the
doctor has an acetate that says do no
harm and if you help me somebody kill
themselves you're surely doing them harm
and not only that I mean we're talking
about assisted suicide man that's a
business and the nature of business is
to grow so if you're going to make it a
business of assisting people with
suicide you can convince anybody besides
you know hey ma'am I want to fatten up
my pocketbook but you got to be at Trump
level salesman to sell people death to
sell kill I mean you have to be that is
the art of the deal
folks but but when you think about it I
mean look at we got
culture right now of cultural suicide
bombers and they're taught from from
childhood that hey you kill yourself you
get what 72 virgins you get something
you get some young boys you know there's
precious pearls you know so you can
actually sell to some people you can
actually create a culture that way
there's a lot more exciting than in some
hospital rooms
my older family members can feel like
they're a burden and even know well
agree have that culture yeah when you
have that culture does older families
can feel like they're a burden and then
kind of go overboard with this kind of
stuff you know they don't really want to
you know so and that's a great point
with it being all about sales and
business as well like do we want the
government in a position especially now
where we have you know more government
involvement in healthcare than we ever
have in United States do we want
government in a position where it can
actually maybe I don't want to say talk
people into killing themselves but be
very certain process exactly that is
going to objectively save them money in
the long term we're talking about these
serious illnesses like I said if you
don't see a conflict of interest there
then I I don't know what to say that's
absolutely yeah go ahead I don't see
this this I don't see this as the glass
half hole because at the same time we're
pushing socialized medicine so what
should you that these are couple
together so once that push you know one
of these bills gets in there and then
you have this culture of death we have
rationed health care and them stuff kind
of take off you do have that culture of
death amplifies and at the core of this
there is an the materialist world view
the world view that says that I don't
have a soul I'm not going anywhere
there isn't a purpose to my life at that
side of me it's only a self actualized
purpose or a self determined one and in
that case then suffering is the worst
thing imaginable right in that case you
could possibly even sell someone death
but we're not going to need any assisted
suicide when the bombs start flying and
that little dictator nukes us all into
oblivion panel thank you for being here
roaming Millennials Oh Rachel and Amanda
Prestidge jacquimo now we have to come
to the final thought
the big kung pao chicken in the room is
that we have not yet discussed much is
China for years the United States has
leaned on China to pressure North Korea
on its nuclear weapons program to
evidently zero success this week China's
vice Commerce Minister insisted quote we
think the North Korea nuclear issue and
China US trade are in two completely
different domains they aren't related
they should not be discussed together
well there's a new sheriff in town and
president Trump has promised to do just
that finally tie trade to North Korean
nukes critics will shriek about the in
efficacy of this tactic but it couldn't
possibly do worse than our previous
quarter century of failed policy on the
peninsula
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow we'll do it
again
[Music]
[Music]